Let's do it. Just watch me. I'm like this here thing. You don't have to get in here and wait
till you see him because he might screw you up.
That was a shit pass. He knows that. He needs to hear it from you.
I'll get it right next time. Hey, that was a shit pass. I'll get better next time.
Right, we're on now. Holding.
Hey, that was a pass. That wasn't a pop. Those 10s had been on you.
You guys weren't ready.
Get your 10s ready.
Hey, look. Make sure they're ready.
Front foot. Front foot low. Wear your hands.
Ready.
Oh, that was a pass. The 10s would have been all over you, man.
Airframe.
Yeah, I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you.
Good. Better.
Here we go. Come on.
Good.
Cover your left. Cover your left.
Right here. Good. Good.
That'll do it.
All right.